was a good night for Paige Vanzant she
got a perfect score for her jive and
arrived at the after party looking
enamored sources tell et that the UFC
fighter is dating dancing troupe member
Alan burnstead the two got closer when
Alan danced with Paige after a partner
Mark Ballas injured his back over on the
voice heightened security for two very
special guests
these Secret Service guys they make me
nervous
Blake rocked it tied to meet the first
lady and dr. Jill Biden who were on hand
for a military tribute so excited to
have the first lady and dr. Biden here
need some strong female energy let's
soak it all in guys definitely a boys
club around here sometime next Sofia
Vergara pretty in pink at an Emmy
consideration event for Modern Family
and telling us that hubby Joe
Manganiello is on the mend after an
unexplained health issue he tweeted a
couple weeks ago he said I love my wife
and our audience went nuts over it what
was behind that tweet why did he say
that I don't know I'm always very
special with him so you must have been
one of my normal days and finally
the F Stevie Tyler was feeling the love
at a concert for charity Janey's find
last night in New York
not spotted Tigers longtime assistant
turned a rumored girlfriend 28 year old
Amy and Preston but he did tell us what
makes her so great she puts up with my
crap daughter Liv was there she's
expecting baby number three dreams I
always like to wait till I meet the baby
before I maybe you have ideas of things
that you like